the biden administration slams border
patrol even as the border remains wide
open democrats seek to blow out the
spending and regulate business into the
ground and the covet hysteria continues
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
slash ben will get to all the news in
just one moment first you may have
noticed that the stock market took a
giant dive earlier this week and then it
sort of climbed back up into reasonable
area later this week because there's an
awful lot of uncertainty regarding the
economy when there's a lot of
uncertainty you might want to take at
least a portion of your savings and put
it into something that has never been
worth zero i'm talking about precious
metals right now you've seen another
month of record inflation that could go
up or maybe we'll just get stagflation
or maybe we won't get inflation we'll
just get economic stagnation in any case
a good store of value has always been
and will continue to be gold my
insurance plan remains gold and silver
from birch gold group if you haven't
reached out to birch school to diversify
your ira or 401k into a precious metals
ira do it today text ben 247 4747 get a
free information kit on protecting your
savings with gold they have an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews thousands of
happy customers talk to them have them
help you safeguard your retirement
savings text ben 247 4747 to claim
you're free no obligation information
kit on holding gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account again text ben to 47
47 47 to take the first step in
protecting your savings today text my
name ben to 47 47 47 and get started
with my friends over at birch gold all
right so joe biden continues to flounder
about i was off for a couple of days i
came back and joe biden continues to be
in the low 40s in approval rating he has
no public events scheduled today which
makes sense since nothing's happening
apparently like nothing we still have
hundreds of americans trapped behind
enemy lines in afghanistan we have a
giant crisis over at the border
we have unemployment rate ticking up at
least more jobless claims this month
we've seen a lot of not great headlines
from this administration but listen joe
biden needs his nap he needs his rest
and unlike yours truly where i take
religiously designated days of rest
typically joe biden just needs a day of
rest like once every couple of days if
god worked for six days and on the
seventh he rested joe biden works for
six hours and for the rest of the week
he rests that's essentially what he does
and in those six hours he creates whole
universes of problems the problem at the
southern border continues to fester
according to politico
the mass of thousands of haitians at the
u.s southern border has put the biden
administration in the exact place it's
tried to avoid knee deep in immigration
politics well that's the true tragedy is
that things might be bad for joe biden
that's the true problem here in the past
24 hours the white house has responded
to images and videos of aggressive
tactics used by border patrol agents to
corral those migrants by supporting an
internal investigation into the matter
what it hasn't done yet is figure out a
solution to the crowding and sanitary
issues arising in what's become a
makeshift encampment or stop its policy
of deporting migrants upon arrival
that's left the president and his team
with few supporters and allies this is
according to politico a coalition of
more than 38 civil rights and immigrant
advocacy leaders sent the white house a
letter on tuesday evening calling on
biden to immediately stop expulsions of
all haitians some of whom arrived at the
border community of del rio texas after
fleeing violence and natural disaster in
their home country well here's one
problem with that particular narrative a
huge percentage of the haitians who are
now arriving are not arriving directly
from haiti i mean they're showing up in
del rio texas which suggests that they
are not in fact taking a boat from haiti
to the border of the united states many
of them have been in latin and central
america for years and then now they are
figuring it's a good time to come
because joe biden is president
the letter first provided to politico
marks a final straw said nana giamfi
executive director of the black alliance
for just immigration and presidents of
the national conference of black lawyers
the coalition includes the aclu human
rights watch and the leadership
conference on civil and human rights and
described the moment as a quote-unquote
inflection point for biden's commitment
to a humane immigration policy the
letter says responsibility for the
suffering and deaths resulting from
summary expulsions and removals now
falls squarely on your administration
will be part of your enduring legacy
deportation flights to haiti must stop
those seeking safety at our borders must
be granted their legally assured chance
to seek asylum
meanwhile members of the president's own
party including senate majority leader
chuck schumer echoed the call to end the
expulsions
increasingly they did so while directing
their ire at the white house for its
handling of the situation
this of course
is no great shock the radical left wing
of the party has taken over the entire
party when it comes to immigration and
they are so deeply afraid of the
intersectional coalition that the fact
that these immigrants happen to be
people of color is enough for them to
completely disregard any questions of
legality or process or anything like
that so you have ayanna presley the
democratic massachusetts congresswoman
the adjunct member of the squad the
ringo starr of the squad you might say
she she was out there saying we need to
stop the deportations
haitian lives are black lives and if we
truly believe that black lives matter
then we must reverse course the biden
administration must immediately and
indefinitely halts all deportations of
haitian migrants it must affirm and
guarantee the right to due process for
those seeking asylum and it must use
every resource available to support
those fleeing this humanitarian crisis
on the island
you see it's not that the biden
administration wants to have some sort
of control of the border at least
pretend they have some sort of control
of the border the problem is they're
racist
and the the breakdown of all issues into
intersectional wokeness is really
bizarre and has corrupted a lot of
democratic politics and created a lot of
internacion conflict that frankly is
somewhat enjoyable to watch from a
conservative perspective because you
watch as the left transforms issue
like immigration into issues of pure
racism and suddenly they're calling
members of of their own party racists
for not wanting to simply open the
border wide to people who are crossing
that particular border msnbc had a panel
saying the same sort of thing that what
you're seeing right now is just
america's white supremacy in action so
having borders is now white supremacy
like having a border is which is weird
because if you actually look at mexican
immigration policy for example with
regard to countries to the south of
mexico far harsher than american policy
with regard to illegal immigration and
apparently this all goes back to the
roots of white supremacy when you got a
narrative you got to flog that horse
until it's you know well past the point
of death we'll get to the flogging of of
horses in a second because that becomes
of relevance in a moment here's an msndc
panel doing the same routine
it's not surprising right that given the
white supremacist roots of this nation
that our immigration system is also
reflective of that anti-blackness that
exists and so you know the the situation
that we have right now jeff is that we
have the biden administration that has
prioritized racial equity in racial
justice and for this to be happening for
black migrants to be deported for
haitian migrants to be deported to a
country that is suffering a recent
earthquake in a political assassination
of their president
this is just completely unacceptable
so you can't support anybody if you
believe the black lives matter you
cannot support anyone under any
circumstances if you believe in the
intersectional coalition so biden's
being attacked from his left he's also
being attacked from his rights we'll get
to that in just one second again all of
this is brought about by not having any
sort of consistent policy with regard to
the border biden wants to say that he
has a border policy and that he's going
to take measures to secure the border at
the same exact time that he ripped on
trump for having a border policy the
predictable result a bunch of people
showing up at the border and a bad photo
op for joe biden at the very least we'll
get some more of this in just one second
first let's discuss the simple fact that
if you are in incognito mode when you
use the internet it actually it doesn't
help you all that much i mean the
reality is that your isp can still see
exactly what you are doing to really
stop people from seeing the sites you
visit you need to do what i do and use
express vpn think about all the times
you've used wi-fi at a coffee shop or a
hotel even at your parents house without
expressvpn every site you visit could be
logged by the admin of the network that
is still true even when you're in
incognito mode what's more your home
internet provider can also see and
record your browsing data and in the
united states they are legally allowed
to sell that data to advertisers
expressvpn is the app i use it encrypts
all of your network data it reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
your private online activity stays just
that private expressvpn works on all
your devices it is super easy to use the
app literally has one button you tap it
to connect your browsing activity is
secure from prying eyes so stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy
protect yourself at expressvpn.com
pen use my link at
expressivevpn.com to get three extra
months for free that's expr essvpn.com
slash ben to learn more
expressvpn.com to get the three extra
months for free okay so biden is being
attacked from his left he's also being
attacked from his right tulsi gabber
democratic congresswoman who recently
ran for president she blasted biden she
tweeted out the humanitarian and
national security crisis on the southern
border is the direct result of your open
border policy
as i said in my 2020 presidential
campaign we can't have a secure nation
if we don't secure our borders
meanwhile the border patrol is blasting
the white house the union characterized
the white house as inept for failing to
have any plan in place to deal with the
influx of some 15 000 migrants that left
agents completely overwhelmed brandon
judd president of the national border
patrol council provided texts from
emails he said the union had sent to the
administration all the way back in june
warning about the influx influx of
migrants in del rio
in the text the union suggested a way to
process the crowds more smoothly but
apparently the response from management
in the border patrol's del rio sector
according to the union was that several
other platforms were being considered
which were more efficient
okay so all of this is a running
disaster and the bite administration of
course has
no actual plan to deal with any of it in
fact there are now reports that haitian
migrants are simply being released into
the interior of the united states
according to the associated press
haitians have been freed on a very very
large scale in recent days according to
one u.s official with direct knowledge
of operations so while the biden
administration is saying oh yeah we're
taking people or putting them on planes
we're flying them back in reality
literally thousands of haitians are
being simply sent into the interior of
the united states are they being coveted
tested by the way i have serious doubt
any sort of criminal background check on
that are we just releasing people into
the interior of the united states in
order to comply with the intersectional
dictat of the woke left in the
democratic party the official who is not
authorized to discuss the matter and the
spoken condition of anonymity put the
figure in the thousands in the thousands
according to the ap a second u.s
official also with direct knowledge and
speaking on the condition of anonymity
said large numbers of haitians were
being processed under immigration laws
and not being placed on expulsion for
flights to haiti that started on sunday
and according to nbc news for haitians
hoping to get to the united states the
administration's decision to release
many people is a welcome relief three
hours after leaving the makeshift camp
under the international bridge with his
pregnant wife
mackenzie vallarde stood outside a gas
station in del rio texas waiting on a
greyhound bus to take the couple to a
cousin who is living in san antonio
so the bible administration says oh yeah
yeah it's not us we're trying we've told
people not to come and that if they come
they'll be turned back but um
also we might just release them into the
interior of the united states we might
just do that as well
all of this is is
incredible and insane and of course very
very bad meanwhile apparently there are
reports that the biden administration is
trying to use gitmo as a place to house
some of these migrants we'll see how it
goes with the left wing of the
democratic party when joe biden starts
shipping haitian migrants to gitmo
according to nbc news the biden
administration is advertising for a new
contract to operate a migrant detention
facility at the u.s naval base at gitmo
with a requirement that some of the
guards speak spanish and haitian crayola
according to government records a
little-known immigrant holding facility
has a capacity of 120 people it will
have an estimated daily population of 20
people according to the records formal
bidding is expected to take place later
this fall
again aoc nowhere to be found where
exactly is aoc and her white outfit at
gitmo protesting the treatment of these
haitian migrants after all doesn't she
care as iona presley says about these
people of color or only when trump is
president does she pretend to care about
all of this happening
remember this is all because the adults
are back in charge
and we were told that these are the
adults these are the in fact there are
such adults that the special envoy for
haiti
the ambassador daniel foote
a career member of the foreign service
has now resigned he says he will not be
associated with us's inhumane
counterproductive decision to deport
thousands of haitians
he says the people of haiti mired in
poverty hostage to the terror
kidnappings robberies and massacres of
armed gangs suffering under corrupt
government with gang alliances simply
cannot afford the forced infusion of
thousands of returned migrants lacking
food shelter and money without
additional avoidable human tragedy the
collapsed state is unable to provide
security or basic services more refugees
will fuel further desperation and crime
surging migration to our borders will
only grow as we add to haiti's
unacceptable misery haitians need
immediate assistance to restore the
government's ability to neutralize gangs
and restore order through the national
police so basically it's our job to fix
haiti according to this particular
ambassador and because the bite
administration is not doing that then um
he is going to leave he says the hubris
that makes us believe we should pick the
winner again is impressive the cycle of
international political interventions in
haiti has consistently produced
catastrophic results more negative of
impacts to haiti will have calamitous
consequences not only in haiti but in
the united states and our neighbors in
the hemisphere all of this is leading to
a mass exodus according to the wall
street journal
quote the gathering of thousands of
haitians at the texas mexico border this
past week reflects a stark change in
migration patterns to the us driven by
covet 19. oh is that is that what it is
it's the kova 19 of it is it because
kova 19 i noticed started you know like
last march and it seems like the giant
drive toward the northern border of
mexico and the southern border of the
united states uh that really started to
ratchet up as joe biden approached
becoming president of the united states
a far broader mix of nationalities is
turning up at the border then in the
past for decades most crossers were
mexican men in recent years families
from troubled central american countries
of guatemala honduras and el salvador
known as the northern triangle suddenly
ecuadorians brazilians nicaraguans
venezuelans haitians and cubans are
turning up by the hundreds of thousands
a trend that accelerated sharply in the
past six months from october 2020
through august nearly 300 000 migrants
from countries other than mexico and the
northern triangle were encountered at
the border a fifth of all crossings for
all of fiscal 2020 when the pandemic
slowed the flow of migrants the figure
was nearly 44 000 or 11
of crossings in fiscal 2019 it was 77
000 or nine percent of crossings so now
again it's like 20 of all crossings are
from countries other than mexico and the
northern triangle
why because they see the joe biden as
president and they understand that joe
biden cannot make up his mind whether he
actually wishes to enforce the border or
whether he wishes to attack the border
patrol
and in the end as always joe biden is is
basically going to side with the radical
left joe biden is already moving towards
siding with the radical left because he
can't take the blow back from his own
base remember joe biden was elected
based on the promise that he was going
to be moderate and now everything he is
doing is basically no different than
anything that bernie sanders would have
done
i mean bernie sanders have now because
if you go like 10 years ago bernie
sanders was actively anti-illegal
immigration if you ask bernie sanders
about borders like 10 years ago he
sounded exactly like donald trump the
white house for its part says it doesn't
even know how many haitians have been
deported
which is obviously the sign of a great
policy you have no idea how many people
you've deported and how many people
you're releasing into the interior of
the united states here's jen saki doing
her utmost to try and again
make up the bed for the guy who just
pooped it
do you have the numbers how many
patients have been deported how many
have been processed and how many have
been allowed to stay in the united
states i certainly understand why you're
asking and understand why people have
been asking secretary mayorkas those are
numbers that are uh the secretary the
department of homeland security would
have the most up-to-date numbers but why
is it so hard to keep track of a simple
number like that why can't you give it
why can't he give it it's been two days
now he's been asked i'm certain they
will provide it it's an absolutely fair
question to ask and i'm certain he just
wanted to have the most up-to-date
numbers to provide
so
once again that's going to be a no on
any sort of relevant numbers just as
they had no idea how many americans were
trapped behind enemy lines in
afghanistan there's a shocking lack of
numbers when it comes to how many
migrants they're actually deporting and
how many they're releasing into the
interior of the united states you might
say that they're just lying to you you
might say that they probably have this
data they're just never going to give
you this data you may notice that all of
your favorite commentators who are
talking about the
adults in the room all the people on the
left who suggest that this is a
data-driven administration will never
give you one iota of data to support a
single position they are taking whether
it is coveted whether it is migration or
whether it is afghanistan they have no
stats to offer you and if they offer you
a stat they immediately cover it in a
drool of sycophantic nonsense about how
biden is in control of the situation
it's just ridiculous so when you're in
trouble what do you do well you do what
the left typically does you attack the
law enforcement we'll get to that in
just one second first
let's talk about a simple fact the
reality is that you need life insurance
you do i mean let's say that you are
walking down the street and for some
reason you're just walking underneath an
apartment where they're lifting a piano
into the apartment and then the string
breaks the piano lands directly on you
well as the lifeblood seeps from your
prone body you might think to yourself
man i really should have gotten life
insurance i should have listened to
shapiro and he said head on over to
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare well you could say 50 or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius in fact you could save 300
bucks or more per year on life insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies the licensed experts at policy
genius work for you not the insurance
companies so you can trust them to help
you navigate every step of the shopping
and buying process that kind of service
has earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call this
exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor higher than
options from ladder ethos and bestow
getting started is simple first head on
over to policygenius.com shapiro in a
minute you can work out how much life
insurance coverage you need compare
personalized quotes policy genius team
will handle all the rest head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro's
policygenius.com slash apparel get
started right now policygenius.com slash
apparel policy genius because when it
comes to insurance it's nice and quite
important to get it right okay so
when you're in trouble if you are the
democrats just blame the people who are
in charge of implementing the policy
and when you have a spike in crime in
major cities around the united states
you blame the cops after you attack the
cops which is why they stopped enforcing
the laws against crime so you tell
people on the border do not enforce the
law on the border then they don't
enforce the law on the border then you
tell them you need to enforce the law on
the border then they start to enforce
the law on the border and when there's
blowback you're like god those people
who are enforcing the law i can't
believe those people they're just
terrible so over the last three days we
have seen this myth that has now taken
on
epic proportions that border patrol
agents are going around whipping people
if they're going around actually taking
whips and hitting people with whips
there is no evidence to this none okay
there is not a single piece of evidence
number one the border patrol doesn't
have whips
and there's not a single law enforcement
agency in the united states that has
whips because we don't live in the slave
holding south and we also don't live in
like 13th century europe okay nobody
goes around with a whip on their belt
that is not a thing
okay beyond that they've now claimed
that well that even if they weren't
using whips they're using the reins of
their horses as whips
okay the evidence that they have been
using the reins of their horses as whips
is that there are pictures of them
with the reins of their horses which are
long reigns that you actively use in
order to direct a horse i may be no
horseman
i'm in i'm a city jew but let me just
tell you
even i know because i have seen a
western why
i mean have you have these people never
even seen a western like they use the
reins in order to hit the horse to make
the horse go in a particular direction
you don't have to be some sort of
western expert to understand what the
border patrol agents are doing but if
you take a photo in a particular
position
then it makes it look as though perhaps
these border patrol agents are actively
going around just smacking the hell out
of the migrants who are crossing
illegally
okay all of this has led to a massive
news cycle in which the biden
administration gets to be on the right
side of history you see this is all
about trying to struggle to find a
narrative where they're on the right
side now they say they're not
responsible for their own border patrol
right so remember the border patrol is
run by the administration
i'll also note a bit of a disconnect
here the rule apparently in the bite
administration is if you drone an
innocent family in afghanistan based on
taliban intelligence nobody gets fired
however if somebody takes a photo of you
taking the reins of your horse and
hitting the flank of your horse with the
reins from a particular angle there
might be a full-scale federal
investigation so probably you should
have just chosen to work in dod and
drone a bunch of kids if you've done
that then the administration's like
wow those guys they're doing their job
like droning the kids that was part of
the job description but what was not
part of the job description of being a
border patrol agent is apparently using
the reins to hit your horse on its flank
in a compromising angle this is what we
definitely have to avoid
by the way it is worth noting here that
there are federal charges coming against
haitian illegal aliens for attacking u.s
pilots biting ice agents according to
reports so it's not as though all of the
migrants who are coming into conflict
with border patrol and ice are somehow
all wonderful people who are all not
doing anything to violate the law other
than seeking a better life there's some
people who are actually like attacking
border patrol agents according to the
daily wire haitian illegal immigrants
who are in the process of being removed
from the us after they broke u.s federal
immigration laws allegedly attacked u.s
pilots and several ice agents including
biting at least two agents the
washington examiner reported federal
assault charges will be brought against
two haitian migrants after they bit
federal law enforcement officials on
board a deportation flight when the
plane was taxiing to the runway
so yeah things are going fantastically
well the white house however is in
full-scale investigate mode it's time to
based again on a lie basically there was
a picture that was taken again of a
border patrol agent with long reigns in
his hand and a migrant who's kind of
beside his horse and people are like
they're whipping the migrants they're
whipping the migraines
okay
what are
okay how about some video there are
cameras there the whole time have we
seen any video so far of them actively
taking
the reins and smacking migrants with the
reins has any of that video emerged and
we've missed it
okay there was a whole article
in usa today about border patrol agents
on horseback whipping haitian immigrants
and then they had to issue a correction
where they said oh the el paso times has
updated story to reflect that it's
reported had witnessed at least one
border patrol agent on horseback swing
his reigns like a whip
toward whom
the horse
and what
so the white house is in full scale
investigation mode because again it is
all about covering ass and if you can
attack border patrol you don't have to
talk about the fact that your policy is
a complete and utter failure or
depending on whether your policy is mass
migration entering the united states a
complete and utter success you just
don't want to tell people about what
your real goals are we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
keeping your home safe and secure as you
can tell i'm filming today from the road
that means that i'm regularly accessing
my ring alarm security system i'm much
more at ease when i'm on the road or
away from home because of ring my ring
alarm equals peace of mind protect your
home with ring alarm
ring alarm it's a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app for a special offer head
on over to ring.com ben it's the perfect
way to start your ring experience you
can keep an eye on every corner of your
house with the indoor and outdoor cams
you can see what's happening directly
from your phone protect your home
anytime from anywhere with ring alarm
go to ring.com for a special offer on a
ring alarm security kit today one things
i love about ring i got three kids
they're all crazy they run around they
evade my detection well with ring they
no longer evade my eyes because my ring
device allows me to see them
you can build the system right for your
home have it up and running in just
minutes head on over to ringgit.com
that is ring.com
once more ring.com
for a special offer on the ring alarm
security kit today okay so as i say
there were all of these reports on
twitter
of
border patrol agents whipping people
whipping people so the white house now
says it is seeking more information on
this
so jen saki expressed her outrage at all
of this oh it's just
i'm outraged at all of this okay well
then you might have actually you know
what solves all this by the way let's
say for for the sake of argument that
there were actual abuses in which border
patrol agents were smacking migrants
with the reins of that they used on the
horse you know what to solve that
i can think of a device that would have
solved this like really it's kind of old
it's kind of an ancient technology
see what you do is you put a brick on
top of another brick then you put like a
crap load of bricks all together
and you put it up like real high
and then you build this brick structure
all along the border you might call it a
wall
right and and maybe
you campaign on that and maybe democrats
then obstruct the building of that and
then they're mad when border patrol
agents have to police the unwalled areas
yeah anyway okay so jensaki she she said
that she was very upset about she says
i've seen some of the footage i don't
have the full context i can't imagine
what context would make that appropriate
i don't have additional details i
certainly don't have additional context
i don't think anyone seeing that footage
would think it was appropriate or
acceptable videos taken by al jazeera
and reuters appear to show law
enforcement officers on horseback using
aggressive tactics including swinging
long reigns near migrants who crossed
the us mexico border near del rio texas
near migrants they didn't actually hit
them with the rains
they had the rains near the migrants
like in the general vicinity of the
migrants i want to see any of these
people honestly try to enforce the law
and then they're very angry also because
they're videos of border patrol agents
grabbing migrants who are attempting to
get across the board and then just take
off into the interior of texas so i have
a question what do they think law
enforcement actually involves
like seriously what do they think law
enforcement involves do you hand people
a lollipop
what exactly are they supposed to do
when people take off for the interior
of the united states without being
processed in any way i mean honestly
they probably should they should
probably just let people go at this
point since the biden administration
just skipped the middleman and the
bottom administration is bringing people
to a processing facility then giving
them a bus ticket to san antonio and
being like be on your way good sir so
you could just if you're the border
patrol you could just be like welcome in
enjoy the this land is your land this
land is my land
in an al jazeera video a law enforcement
officer on horseback is seen swirling
long reigns near a group of migrants
shortly beforehand another individual on
horseback is heard yelling at the
migrant saying you use your women this
is why your country is bleep because you
use your women for this
um so it is unclear what prompted that
why they why they were yelling about
using women is it possible that somebody
was hiding behind a woman as they
attempted to flee into the interior
because you might see the outrage there
you might see why that would be
unjustified in any case this this all
must be investigated this is all like
the big issue here is not the tens of
thousands of people descending on the
united states border every single
hundreds of thousands of people over the
past few months millions by the end of
the year
none of that is the issue the issue is
the border patrol the people you put in
a position to actually police the border
if you can crap on them then the left
will celebrate you even as you set up
gitmo and even as you ship out some
haitians on flights back to haiti here
is alejandro mayorkas the head of dhs
expressing his outrage over all of this
i was horrified by what i saw
i am going to let the investigation run
its course but the pictures that i
observed
troubled me profoundly
that defies
um all of the values that we seek to
instill in our people any mistreatment
or abuse of an individual defies
the our values and who we are and what
we stand for
uh who we are and what we stand for is
apparently open borders and crapping on
anyone who attempts to actually enforce
the law now listen if there are abuses
people should be investigated and
prosecuted unless they drone kids in
afghanistan then we give them a medal
but if they are abusive in the sense
that they say a bad thing
or if they
use their reins
on their horses in the general two-mile
vicinity of people who are attempting
across the border illegally then
obviously we have to spend our days
talking about how they're using it like
whips
this prompted kamala harris who
i thought was her job to get the border
under control where where is she why
isn't she policing the border didn't joe
biden put her in charge of border policy
so she's an abject failure at that like
she is at everything else but she keeps
failing upwards here's kamala harris
blasting border patrol
what i saw depicted about um those
individuals on horseback
treating human beings the way they were
is horrible
and i fully support what is happening
right now which is a thorough
investigation into exactly what is going
on there
um but human beings should never be
treated that way
and i'm deeply troubled about it
okay by the way you know what border
patrol is going to do they're going to
do exactly what cops everywhere have
done they're basically just going to be
like okay
all right like come on in
because why would you risk being caught
by a photographer swinging your reins at
your horse and there's a migrant nearby
or i'm saying something in politic to
somebody who maybe is using their uh a
woman or a child to some sort of shield
you're not going to be caught doing that
right you're just going to let people go
which is of course what the bible
administration means to do in terms of
policy but at least the democrats are
pleasing their base at least joe biden
is pleasing his base maxine waters who's
just a nut case she says that what we
are witnessing here is worse than
slavery worse than slavery
what the hell are we doing here
what we witness
takes us back hundreds of years
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery
cowboys
with their reigns again
whipping
black people
haitians
into the water where they're scrambling
and falling down when all they're trying
to do is escape
from violence in their country
okay so i can see a few distinctions one
we're not enslaving any of those people
two all those people are attempting to
enter the united states
okay it turns out that slaves did not
actually want to be in the situation of
slavery now you're saying that haitians
attempted to escape in the united states
who are being
deterred by the border patrol are the
equivalent of slaves
who are being held as property
by
fellow americans
in the most immoral act in american
history
so um no on that that's a no on that
well here here's the good news if you
just rip on law enforcement you never
actually have to come to grips with the
fact that your body your policy just
blows it's just a terrible policy and
everyone knows it and the facts are on
the screens and you can try to cover it
up by spending all of your time talking
about how in favor of human rights you
are well reopening gitmo shipping people
back to haiti and ripping on the border
patrol agents who you have now tasked
with controlling the border
that that can be your policy it's just
not a very good policy the good news is
that we have a fully cognizant and with
it president of the united states who's
perfectly transparent loves to answer
questions from the press really wants to
be honest with the american people which
is why he will answer no questions from
the american people or answer questions
from the press so the other day he had
boris johnson in the oval office and uh
they had this little photo op
and then it was supposed to end and
boris john or the boris johnson the
prime minister of the uk he was like oh
i'm happy to take questions and joe
buttons like
and so you get the odd spectacle of
boris johnson meaning i'm happy to take
questions in the media like okay i don't
really want to talk to you but the guy
next to you you know the one who's
presiding over this entire disaster we
got some questions for him and joe biden
just kind of like shrinking and
shriveling into a ball and all the aids
being like get those people the hell out
of here what are they even doing here
these press people with their pressing
this journalism must stop immediately
don't they understand their job is
simply to carry water for the old man
the old man needs them to carry water
and joe biden's over there like snoozing
and drooling into a cup and jill is
massaging his shoulder it's so weird
here's the here's a little bit of that
i think nobody wants to see anything
that uh interrupts or uh unbalances the
the belfast good friday uh accord that's
the
uh belfast good friday agreement that's
that's the
no get the hell out of here you're not
you will not ask questions of the old
man who is destroying our border policy
destroying our economy destroying
federalism and wrecking our foreign no
there will be no questions for this old
gentleman over here stop being mean to
the nursing home patient
jensachi basically said that right the
white house press secretary was asked
about this
and she says we're mad at boris johnson
and we're super mad at boris johnson
because boris johnson answers questions
from the press this is an actual defense
by the press secretary it's not good
it's not a good defense
the british prime minister in the
american oval office called out british
reporters and then when american
reporters tried to call on the american
president
we were
escorted out we'll put it that way well
i think
in that circumstance and and i think our
relationship with the united kingdom and
with prime minister johnson is so strong
and abiding we will be able to move
forward beyond this but uh he called on
individuals from his press corps without
alerting us to that intention in advance
he didn't tell them
bojo is wrong because bojo didn't tell
them he was going to take questions and
that never happened remember this is an
entire administration constructed around
the premise that this
barely warm corpse of a human is
actually running things and is capable
of running things i mean he is he's
making some baseline decisions and then
everybody else is going and implementing
they're scurrying around to please the
old man and meanwhile the old man won't
answer any questions to the extent that
his own press corps
are being
basically policed by the internal press
secretaries of the white house joe biden
is being handed lists of reporters to
call on at press conferences and they'll
be like they've got an appointment for
me later i gotta i'm gonna go see
the proctologist
like oh
unbelievable performance by the
president of the united
stand of confidence being exhibited
every single day can we get to the
shocking competence of this
administration when it comes to the
economy which is teetering on the brink
first let's talk about a simple fact a
lot of people are out hiring right now
it can be tough to find the best
employees right now there are like 10
million open jobs in the united states
and not enough people to fill those jobs
well this is one time it would be
excellent to use zip recruiter
businesses are turning to zip recruiter
to fill those roles check them out at
ziprecruiter.com dailywire when you post
a job on zip recruiter they will send
your job to over 100 top job sites
giving you access to their network of
millions of job seekers
zip recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and then proactively
presents them to you you can easily
review recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
that encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zip recruiter technology is
so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within day one right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address ziprecruiter.com dailywire that
is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just head on over to
ziprecruit.com
dailywire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire alrighty we'll get
to more on this in a moment the
collapsing economy because it is it is
slowing at the very least and it is
because of joe biden's covered policy
and because of his economic policy it's
because the federal reserve has
basically been tasked with doing all
economic policy and people are
disquieted as well they should be first
it's no secret that today's america is
short on truth especially when it comes
to the legacy media that is why the
daily wire started morning wire the
daily morning show dedicated to bringing
you all the news you need to know
without any spin or hidden agenda it's
the only daily podcast that values your
time and the truth while we're working
overtime to make sure fact-based news
still has a platform we do need your
help to keep morningwire trending so
subscribe start listening right now to
morningwire on applespotify wherever you
listen to podcasts leave a five-star
review if you like what you hear you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
remember joe biden came into office and
he made a tripartite promise he was not
going to shut down the economy he was
not going to shut down the country he
was going to stop the virus um all three
of those things are untrue so
this is going very poorly according to
cnbc.com today first time filings for
unemployment benefits jumped last week
hitting the highest level in a month
according to the labor department
initial claims for the week ended
september 18th on a seasonally adjusted
basis totaled 351 000 an increase from
the previous week's upwardly revised 335
thousand
well ahead of the 320 000 dow jones
estimate the total was the highest since
the week of august 21st markets reacted
little to the news stock market futures
pointed to a strong opening safe haven
government bonds saw yields rise an
indication that investors were selling
fixed income as yields move opposite
price well the reason they are selling
fixed income right now is because of
inflation pressures you don't you don't
stay on fixed income when the government
is about to blow money into the economy
that's like the dumbest thing you can do
the inflationary pressures that are
being brought to bear by the federal
government right now
are long-term and they are systemic okay
we're not talking merely about
short-term price bikes we are talking
about the devaluation of the money you
have in the bank unless you go and you
put it in stocks which is why the stock
market continues to rise because people
are looking for a safe haven to put
their money right now
and meanwhile the democrats are enraged
enraged that republicans are standing up
to their big spending plans so when you
already have inflationary pressures
right when you already have the federal
reserve that has been tasked idiotically
with both full employment and monetary
stability okay this is something that
goes back decades the federal reserve
should have one job that is monetary
stability it should not be the job of
the federal reserve to ensure full
employment that is normally the job of a
legislature if you're going to be in
that sort of business having an
independent agency that is designed in
order to inflate or deflate the currency
in order to achieve full employment
essentially puts the federal reserve in
charge of all financial policy in the
united states to the detriment of people
who for example hold savings and live on
fixed incomes
all of this leads to inflationary
pressures that in the end bankrupt you
faster
because you recognize that if you keep
inflating the currency just to take a
quick example if you inflate the
currency year on year at a higher rate
if you keep pumping money into the
economy via federal reserve stimulus or
via legislative stimulus
then for example the fixed income
benefits of social security have to rise
in order to meet that
and if they don't rise
then people start saying where's all my
money and if they do rise who's gonna
pay for that then you need to take out
more debt or you need to increase taxes
everybody knows this is the case but
politics is the art of pushing off the
inevitable in favor of temporary
expediency that is what politics in the
united states has become perfect example
of this is the continuing debt ceiling
debate so here's the thing
the reason we keep heating the debt
ceiling is because we keep taking out
debt that is the reason we hit a debt
ceiling
okay if you don't take out more debt you
don't hit the debt ceiling we are now at
like 29 trillion dollars in national
debt in the united states and we have to
service that national debt right we have
to pay people back because we borrowed
money from them we have to pay off on
the bonds we have to do all that sort of
stuff
that is incumbent upon us and if we
don't you have to take money from places
in the government where it's hit
in order to pay off that that
those debts right we have to take money
from for example social security or from
food stamps or from some of the programs
that are funded and we have to push it
over to the higher priority of paying
off all of the interest on the debt well
every so often we hit the debt ceiling
and parties both parties tend to be like
okay well we'll push it off until next
time we'll push it off until next time
well republicans right now are saying
we're not going to push it off until
next time and we're not going to push it
off until next time because we know the
minute we raise the debt ceiling you
immediately take out debt beyond the
debt ceiling
right this is the little game
if we keep expanding the credit line and
you keep blowing out the credit card
we're idiots to keep expanding the
credit line
so if you want us to raise the debt
ceiling you are going to have to pledge
to
actually come up with a plan to repay
the debt or you know not blow out
trillions of dollars in by the way we do
this with foreign countries all the time
right one of the chief methodologies of
the imf for years really since the end
of the soviet union
the the imf and the world bank
one of the things that they have been
doing since the 80s and 90s is when a
country is heavily in debt they say
listen
we are happy to give you a loan but you
have to show us how you're going to
restructure your economy so you don't
just keep taking out debt and spending
tons of money what the republicans are
saying to the democrats right now is
exactly that
and democrats of course are complaining
like why won't republicans go along with
this we of course have to raise the debt
ceiling it's irresponsible not to raise
the debt ceiling because then we can't
pay off our bills by taking out a second
credit card because that's essentially
what we're doing the debt ceiling is
taking out a second credit card and
republicans are like no you're gonna
have to come up with some sort of plan
to to pay this off and then we'll let
you take out a second credit card but
we're not gonna let you keep blowing out
the spending and take out the second
credit card and democrats are wildly
angry about this what if the risks that
people are feeling in the market have
very little to do with our unwillingness
to take out a second credit card and
more to do with the fact that we now
have a system that reinforces taking out
more and more and more debt without
making any sort of long-term plans for
repaying any of it and that eventually
reality will set in and that reality is
likely to set in sooner rather than
later if you regulate the economy at the
same time you're doing this if you want
to do debt-led growth you have to let
business actually use that debt to
innovate you have to let businesses go
out there and make product you have to
let businesses go out there and invest
in new and creative ways but if you blow
out the debt
and all you do is pump money into
systems that are non-innovative in the
end demand will start to curtail demand
will fall off because you have not
created new cool products for people to
invest in and then you end up with
actual inflation you end up with
stagflation
anyway the democrats are fighting mad at
this it's irresponsible i love this it's
irresponsible not to take out the second
credit card because if we don't take out
the second credit card how are we gonna
pay off the first credit card here's joy
redoing that routine
they're literally willing to destroy the
u.s economy just to own the limbs
republicans are refusing to vote to
increase the debt ceiling which could
have catastrophic results it is so bad
that six former treasury secretaries
wrote a letter imploring congress to
extend the limit saying that allowing an
unprecedented default could cause
serious economic harm
confronted with that reality republicans
say that of course the u.s can't default
on its loans but they refuse to help
democrats in any way
why should they help democrats in any
way democrats should be helping
republicans democrats are in the
majority
all democrats have to do is say we're
not passing a 3.5 trillion dollar budget
along with this 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure package grand total 4.7
trillion dollars inside a month after a
1.9 trillion dollar
boondoggle that we passed back in
february
after spending seven trillion dollars
last year all they have to do is say
we're not doing that and they get their
debt ceiling increase
but they don't actually want to do that
right they just want to keep being
irresponsible here's don lemon pushing
the same idea oh it's the republicans
who are the bad guys weird because i
noticed who's in charge of the senate
and the house
is there any purpose to being in charge
of the senate in the house if you bear
no responsibility for the actual budget
bernie sanders says quote this is a slow
and torturous process when you have 50
people and no votes to spare
and going on to say that he thinks at
the end of the day that they're going to
work it out
that with a battle raging over what
should be a slam dunk and that is the
vote to raise the debt ceiling it should
be a slam dunk i should say it should be
a slam dunk it should be a moment of
bipartisan unity the treasury secretary
is warning of economic catastrophe and
anxious democrats are floating a plan b
raise a debt limit themselves on a
party-line vote
okay then they can just do that they can
they can raise that limit themselves on
a party-line vote if they really need to
and if they really want to or they could
make a deal that's bipartisan in nature
like joe biden once pledged to do what
are the markets seeking right now the
markets are just seeking stability and
they're getting none of it because of
the bad covered policy of this
administration and the bad regulatory
policy of this administration and the
fact that this administration is
obviously obviously attempting to
curtail alternative forms of investment
so that you are forced to basically buy
us government bonds and do things that
the government wants you to do
right the greater top-down commands and
control priorities this administration
combined with their desire to spend
oodles of money is creating utter
turmoil in the markets which is why you
know what restored some level of
semblance to reality to this market so
the market dropped dramatically earlier
in the week why because of the talk
about the debt ceiling because of the
talk about the budget because of all of
that talk
okay now the federal reserve signaled
that it is going to start reversing its
pandemic stimulus programs in november
and could raise interest rates next year
amid risks of a lengthier than
anticipated jump in inflation
the response from the market is that
major u.s indices soared to intraday
highs following the central bank's
statement in other words the markets are
not looking for more loose money the
markets right now are looking for some
semblance of sanity and stability
meanwhile the administration is
providing none of it
the wall street journal reports that the
major us indices jumped literally within
minutes of the federal reserve saying we
are going to start tapering off all of
this spending we're going to start
tapering off the qe
we're going to raise the interest rates
that is because everyone thinks the
government is being irresponsible but
democrats want to be irresponsible
so let's talk about democratic
irresponsibility for a second okay at
the same time that they're talking about
how we need to raise the debt ceiling
they're talking about basically
prohibiting banks from making
responsible decisions
in a little notice story joe biden is
now expected to name a cornell law
professor named saul omarova
comptroller of the currency and this is
a wall street regulatory position
which again all of this stuff is is
patently unconstitutional all these
regulatory positions have nothing to do
with the original structure of the
constitution the administrative state is
a disaster area but this particular pick
should be shocking to wall street
again the goal here of the
administration is command and control
top-down economics because joe biden who
is barely alive knows better than you
how to spend your money and knows better
than banks how to invest for money
according to the wall street journal
president biden plans to nominate a law
professor who has criticized wall street
banks to oversee some of the largest u.s
lenders
biden is expected to tap saul omarova a
cornell university law professor to
become comptroller of the currency which
oversees national banks like jp morgan
chase and bank of america
the occ is an independent bureau of the
treasury department and oversees about
1200 banks with total assets of 14
trillion dollars that's two-thirds of
the total in the us banking system it
makes it one of the most powerful
regulators alongside the fed and the
federal deposit insurance corporation
the powerful comptroller of the currency
has a seat on the board of the fdic as
well as on the financial stability
oversight council a panel of senior
regulators charged with detecting risks
to the financial system
so what does omarova actually want to do
well first of all she's a woman and as
we know that's the important thing
even though women don't exist i mean
we've been told that men can be women
in fact
as we'll discuss in a moment uh the wilk
have now suggested that even if you are
to say woman in a quote like an old
quote will now remove it but
she it's very important that she is a
self-identified woman because she's the
first full-time comptroller to run the 3
500 strong agency since abraham lincoln
signed it into law in 1863
she would likely work to help fulfill mr
biden's campaign push to expand access
to banking services in underserved
communities as part of that effort
should help lend a planned overhaul of
the rules for the community reinvestment
act a decades-old law governing hundreds
of billions of dollars in lending and
investment in low-income areas
and now you might remember the community
reinvestment act the community
reinvestment act was one of the vehicles
that was used to create the 2008 real
estate bubble because the community
reinvestment act was basically the
notion that we had to push banks and to
push private entities or public private
entities like fannie mae freddie mac
into giving loans
at non-repayable rates to people who are
likely to default
she is now going to be in charge of this
okay what's some of the stuff that she's
talked about well
on twitter she criticized this summer's
end to temporary restrictions on big
bank share buybacks and dividends after
the banks performed well in annual
stress tests so she says banks should
not be allowed to buy back their stock
and said we should just have diluted
prices for the stock in a separate tweet
she criticized a news report on
acquisitions by jp morgan quote does the
world need jp morgan to grow bigger or
more powerful just wondering
well i mean the question isn't should
they grow bigger or more powerful the
question is what right do you have to
stop them from making economically
feasible decisions
omarova has called for a shift of
consumer banking deposits from private
firms to the federal reserve she calls
to effectively end banking as we know it
so what you would like is for you not to
deposit your money at a bank
which by the way creates the economic
system that we have because if you
deposit money in a bank your money
doesn't sit in the bank the bank then
lends out the money at an interest rate
to other people who then take that money
and create new products and services if
you leave it with the federal deposit
insurance corporation for example
or the federal reserve
you think the federal government is
going to give out loans on the basis of
loans that are likely to be repaid bank
of america has an interest in its loans
being repaid does the federal government
have any interest in its loans being
repaid
of course not they can just tax you to
fill in the gap and you just take out
more bonds
her 2020 paper endorsed steps to quote
radically redefine the role of a central
bank as the ultimate public platform for
generating modulating and allocating
financial resources in a democratic
economy the people's ledger
the so we're going to turn the federal
reserve into
not just the central bank of the united
states we are going to turn it into
apparently the only bank in the united
states controlled by the federal
government you don't see any sort of
risk to this you don't see why perhaps
wall street is a little shook by this
administration
a republican senate aide said gop
lawmakers are concerned her views are
quote far to the left of anyone we've
seen in the regulatory space
well yeah they are
meanwhile in other news that is likely
to upset investors the federal reserve
is looking into launching a digital
currency now having a digital currency
on its own is not that bad an idea right
digital currencies i'm a big proponent
of bitcoin i'm a big proponent of
ethereum i own some of both
the the idea of a digital currency which
cuts out all of the sort of middlemen
that exist when you do a financial
transaction and they're all sort of like
seven eight institutions every time you
swipe your credit card there's seven or
eight institutions in the middle before
the payment is actually verified right
having a a fed coin for example that is
pegged to the price of something to the
po to the price of the dollar makes some
sense but the problem with creating a
federal reserve currency is that what
you are eventually going to get is the
federal reserve actually controlling how
you spend your dollars if the federal
reserve is where you hold your dollars
right a digital currency
so right now if you own bitcoin you own
it in a place like coinbase right you
have a digital wallet the digital wallet
holds the currency okay if you have a
fed coin like a digital u.s currency is
going to be held by the federal reserve
presumably digitally what if the federal
reserve decides that it is going to
place a negative interest rate on your
savings
but it's going to spur you to spend by
creating a negative interest rate
charging you to hold your money in the
federal reserve system and then making
it nearly impossible for you to take
that money out and invest it in an
alternative form of currency like
bitcoin that's precisely what it seems
like the federal government is now
intent on doing also
do you really think it should be easier
for the federal reserve to distribute
money it is very likely the federal
reserve instead of having to inflate the
currency by buying bonds what if they
just add a few zeros to the ledger and
they just directly deposit all of the
money now what if they just do that
we'll just make we'll give them even
more power
according to cnbc the federal reserve is
pushing ahead with its study into
whether to implement its own digital
currency we'll be releasing a paper on
the issue shortly
no decision has been made on the matter
as of yet the fed does not feel
pressured to do something quickly as
other nations move forward with their
own projects
and now again there could be a fed coin
or there could be a financial
a financial security infrastructure set
up by the united states that facilitates
the use of alternative cryptocurrencies
but that's not what this is likely to be
this is likely to be a chinese style fed
coin in which they can inflate and
deflate the currency
jog you to spend or jog you to save by
central policy
pell said the fed is working proactively
to evaluate whether to issue a central
bank
digital currency and if so in what form
establishing a digital dollar has been
on the fed's radar for more than a year
it announced in may would launch a
deeper examination into the issue with a
paper to follow
advocates say a central bank's digital
currencies the benefits include getting
payments quickly to people in times of
crisis also providing services to the
unbanked right the fact is that there
are a lot of people in poorer areas who
can't get a bank account because
number one they live far from a bank or
number two they're a bad credit risk
so the bank doesn't want to extend them
credit for example or it costs an
overhead charge in order to open a bank
account they can't afford it so they're
just unbanked right a lot of people this
is why people go to payday lenders for
example
okay so that that's actually a good
service it makes sense this is all the
services of bitcoin but brought to you
by the federal government the problem is
when they start manipulating the
currency which is probably what they
will do pell says quote we think it's
really important the central bank
maintain a stable currency and payment
system for the public's benefit that's
one of our jobs
the test for any form of digital
currency put out by central bank is
quote are there clear and tangible
benefits that outweigh any costs and
risks
okay some concerns have been raised that
if the fed does not act more
aggressively the dollar's position as
the global reserve currency could be
challenged but again what most people on
the sort of libertarian rights who are
big into bitcoin are worried about is
not
that the us is going to be out competed
by by china on this although that is a
concern what they are more worried about
is the federal reserve taking over all
of the auspices of decentralized banking
by re-centralizing banking and this is
why
i would be far less concerned about a
fed coin
if they were not simultaneously looking
to heavily regulate crypto right they're
seeking to cut off all alternative
avenues of investment
according to
the
according to bloomberg news today quote
cryptocurrency firms are fighting for
lobbyists and fielding subpoenas in what
could be an existential fight over how
the multi-trillion dollar industry
should be regulated so in other words
what cryptocurrencies basically are is
there a way of you diversifying against
the interests of government that is
basically what cryptocurrencies have
become bitcoin has risen in prices
people have become less sanguine about
the prospects of central governments
actually repaying their debts just like
gold and silver right it's a digital
form of it's a store of value for a lot
of people
secondarily crypto can be used as an
actual currency el salvador recently
said that you can use crypto as a
currency it has yet to gain a full-scale
foothold in the united states for use as
an actual currency with its own value
and it's still dollar denominated in a
lot of places
with all of that said the notion that
you're going to regulate bitcoin so that
it is now a security as opposed to for
example a currency or a commodity is
really dangerous if the federal
government can regulate alternative
forms of currency out of existence
regulate alternative forms of
commodities out of existence because
they're afraid you're going to invest
your money in bitcoin as opposed to the
fed coin
well that just leads to more centralized
power more centralized power is
precisely the opposite of what people
were seeking to achieve with digital
currencies in the first place according
to bloomberg over the last decade the
cryptocurrency market has grown from a
little known project shared among
technologists and libertarians to a
massive largely unregulated sector but
even as the sector has found innovative
ways to record ownership digitally and
transfer money cheaply right that's what
blockchain does the idea is that
blockchain makes it secure to transfer
your money because we can verify every
single transaction
it's also launched savings accounts and
investment funds products regulators say
ought to follow the same rules as those
of traditional financial networks and of
course the senate of the united states
basically tried to kill crypto just a
couple of weeks ago when they
in this 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill they refused any
edits that would have exempted bitcoin
miners from regulations targeting
securities traders
right all of this is dangerous there's a
reason for the for example that china
has been targeting bitcoin right china
has been basically locking down bitcoin
and stopping crypto mining because
they're afraid that people are going to
start moving their money away from
chinese currency and into bitcoin
so what you're seeing from the biden
administration is heavier regulation
shut down the alternative avenues of
investment and we'll maximize the amount
of control that the federal reserve has
over your dollar and maybe
through
new regulatory infrastructure and maybe
through new regulatory appointments
we'll put in place people who basically
shut down the ability of banks to invest
properly and then you wonder why the
economy is slowing because you've
created systemic obstacles to the growth
of the economy
and at the same time you're doing that
you're still locking down the country
over covid where you're still doing the
coveted paranoia routine
i it is amazing every few days i just i
wonder to myself why are we still doing
this when i say this i mean once you're
vaccinated you're good to go and people
have lost their absolute ever-loving
damn minds they've lost their minds okay
every season on average many of the past
seasons for flu have been more dangerous
to children for example than covet has
been over the lifelong course of coven
and those are just the death stats on on
the flu versus the death stats on kovid
for children and yet we are still
locking down in parts of the country
this is a question of policy it is not a
question of delta what the media and
democrats keep seeking to do is blame
delta for their own bad policy decision
so when the economy slows based on their
bad policy decisions and based on their
covered lockdowns they say that's
delta's fault that's not our fault for
locking down
that is that is the viruses fault it's
existential circumstance extraneous
circumstances dictating all of this the
problem is all this is predicated on the
lie that they know how to actually stop
this
and the reality is of course that they
don't know how to stop this stuff
i mean they really don't
after mandating masks outdoors for
example in oregon oregon's active coven
19 crisis have increased oregon's active
coven 19 cases have increased i kid you
not 73 percent
according to jim gary reporting for
national review on august 24th oregon
governor kate brown insisted in stated
rather a state masking requirement that
requires everyone five years and older
regardless of vaccination status to wear
a mask face covering or face shield in
outdoor spaces if they're less than six
feet apart from individuals not in their
household
then she says cases and hospitalizations
are at a record high masks are a quick
and simple tool we can immediately
deploy um on august 24th oregon had
about 50 000 active cases as of
yesterday oregon had 87 000 active cases
so those masks really working their
magic meanwhile new york city is
attempting to lock everybody down again
the mta has said they are going to start
issuing 50 fines to riders for not
wearing masks which i guess is a great
way of raising money for the bankrupt
mta
according to new york cbs local wearing
masks on buses and subway trains has
already been the rule for months many
people aren't following it the mta says
its warning period is over
it's not just about protecting people
from crime it's about protecting people
from covid well i mean they're not
protecting people from either crime or
covet but they're going to start handing
out fines which is just a way of of them
raising money
and it's going to be fun to watch the
wailing and gnashing of teeth by the
intersectional left when it turns out a
disproportionate number of those fines
are going to black and hispanic
americans which is likely what is going
to happen
okay meanwhile there's a new study out
suggest that covet is becoming more
airborne
is evolving to become more airborne and
have a higher viral load according to
the jerusalem post and newer variants of
cyrus clover ii the virus that causes
cloven 19 may become more airborne as
they evolve according to a recent study
from the university of maryland
published in the clinical infectious
diseases journal last week
people infected with the alpha strain of
covenant are exhaling 43 to 100 times
more of the virus into the air compared
to those infected with the original
calvin 19 strain
the research found the viral load in the
air from alpha was 18 times more than
could be explained by the increased
amounts of virus in nasal swabs and
saliva
researchers found that face coverings
like surgical mass and clots reduce the
amount of virus breathed out into the
air by about 50 percent there's only one
problem if you are breathing 18 times
more virus than you were before and then
you decrease it
by 50 you're still breathing out nine
times more virus than you were before
so good luck with that
but that's not stopping again this is
this is all crazy
hey i know many people who've gotten
covered after wearing masks
my niece got covered after wearing a
mask at school you know what she was
fine because she's a child
the bottom line is this we now have a
vaccine vaccine is highly effective
against hospitalization and death
now we're done but we can't be done
because people have decided that they
have the capacity to control everything
and just as with the economy everything
can be controlled it's an almost pagan
ritualistic
subservience to the notion that if we
just wish hard enough and mobilize fast
enough we can stop any problem and it's
not true
that's why i have to honestly what anne
hathaway and ciara and all these other
stars did this weekend over the over the
course of the past week
it's just as effective in stopping covet
as any of these government policies
apparently so what did they do they
wrote an open letter to covid
according to the new york post the covet
19 pandemic is still raging on nearly
two years after the disease was first
identified have no fear hollywood is
here to help 70 entertainers signed an
open letter to world leaders in a plea
to help stymie the spread of kovid
an open letter
wow
and kovid saw and coveted quaked the
letter was constructed by the global
nonprofit care
model iman is the organization's global
advocate and helped urge leaders to
increase their vaccination efforts the
letter was published tuesday it
coincides with the u.n general assembly
and the global kova 19 summit hosted by
biden by the way biden hosted that
summit and then he said let's do this
again next year not kidding really
happened
the memo asks leaders to provide
vaccines for 70 of the world's
population by 2022.
it also requests resources for countries
with lower capital more support for
healthcare workers as well as a vested
interest in public education the letter
says none of us are safe until all of us
are safe
then what are the vaccines for
none of us are safe until all of us are
safe no
everyone who's vaccinated to say what
are you talking about
we call on leaders gathering at the un
general assembly to boldly act together
to end covet 19 everywhere
wow well you know if maylen ackerman and
debbie allen
and bobby burko i don't even know and
jordana brewster and connie britton
signed a letter
oh my god alexander d'addario signed the
letter richard gear is on here
unbelievable
covet covet is over man they they they
they did it we did it guys we to get
joel mchale and alyssa milano signed a
letter with edward james almost and zach
posen
sarah silverman signed a letter with
michelle williams against kovid i can't
well problem solved
the reason i'm making fun of this is
only because these people are only
slightly more effective than most
governments have been in actually
stopping covet the only thing that has
stopped cobit in any serious way has
been either you're an island and you
just are a fascist island like australia
has become or
you decide to vaccinate
and huge swaths of people vaccinate
those are the only things
okay so those are your choices because
the choice of not getting covet is is
really not a choice at this point but
we're just going to continue panicking
and then blaming
the virus for our own stupid panic
meanwhile rhonda sansa is continuously
the bad guys to the governor of florida
yesterday he banned quarantine mandates
for students exposed to coven okay
because this has been the standard in
europe for a long time right is that if
you are in a room and you're a child and
you're exposed to covet from another
child and you're asymptomatic you don't
have to quarantine for 10 days because
it's really dumb and otherwise we're
just gonna have to shut down all human
interactions forever here's rhonda sansa
spanning it but this makes him a bad guy
we are going to be following a
symptoms-based approach
if somebody is symptomatic of course
they stay home if there's a close
contact but somebody has not developed
any symptoms you monitor them you notify
the parent the parent always has the
right to make to have their kids stay
home if they think that's in the best
interest of the student and the family
100 percent we would not want to intrude
on that but if a parent has a healthy
child
that child uh you know has a right has a
right to be in school
okay um he is correct about that but
this makes him the bad guy because again
ron desantis refuses to suggest that
government actors can control all
aspects of life
because they can't
because they can't but this makes them
the bad guy the good guys are the people
who want to control every aspect of your
life except apparently for the southern
border because if you control the
southern border this makes you a racist
man the experts are back in charge and
ain't it wonderful can't you feel that
things are going great alrighty we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content coming up soon as the
matte wall show airs at 1 30 pm eastern
be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crans the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show